they can't get our planes to fly but
they want to block the sky Biden's new
plan is bold but it will leave us all
cold the White House is said to be open
to considering a radical new way to
address global warming by attempting to
literally block the Sun
that's according to a congressionally
mandated report from the Biden
Administration on the study of something
called solar radiation modification or
as they call it around the West Wing
that thing Joe can't pronounce
the concept known as geoengineering
would involve chemically altering the
Atmosphere by increasing aerosols and
manipulating how and when certain clouds
form across the globe so breathe easy
it's air pollution but it's good
all that's left is to figure out how
Bill Gates can make money off it yeah
in theory the strategy could drastically
cool the planet but it may also disrupt
global weather patterns or Worse make me
even paler
is that me that's I had an albino tell
me recently I needed to get some sun
In fairness the White House said in a
statement accompanying the report there
are no plans underway to establish a
comprehensive research program focused
on solar radiation modification so rest
easy we're open to blocking out the sun
we're just not doing it yet but if we do
we're ready to kill people to save the
planet
so uh Joey I I I don't know I think did
you see the Matrix they said it was
humans who blocked out the sun they
called it we're not supposed to be
messing around with this kind of stuff
yeah but we're supposed to do it in some
really cool way like nuclear war you
know like we just guns Ablaze and take
everybody out and if you can get a deep
enough hole you can survive this is a
real weak just kind of like just
terrible way to do it right I'm gonna
throw a little bacteria or something
into the sky and block out the Sun and
then like how do your solar panels work
you know or like like how do you you
know what this is this is an or else
scenario they're saying if you don't get
on board with you know not running a gas
car or not cooking your pizza then we're
going to block out the Sun so I better
get on board that's what this is yeah I
know if this Joe if this wasn't weird
why would be they'd be denying that
they're doing it they're saying no no
there's no plans to do this but we know
they're studying it we see the
literature on it they say that all the
time that there's no plans to do that
then you don't have a gas stove anymore
yeah they're like there was no plans to
take away your stove that we took away
yeah it's funny that we're coming full
circle here because they're using these
Scare Tactics to say don't pollute and
then when we finally don't pollute
because they've already taken away our
car and our stove and made our air
conditioner horrible uh they're gonna be
like okay everybody pollution's good
again
yeah
Morgan yeah the
the I don't see I don't really
understand the science of this they're
gonna it's essentially it's chemicals
they're putting chemicals in the
atmosphere and they hope it's going to
reflect the sun back but they even admit
if we do this we don't know the side
effects so they want to like spray mRNA
into the sky I don't like it see I grew
up uh in Florida and I've I think like
everybody I know oh God Floridians are
here yet
[Applause]
[Music]
I feel like everyone from Florida that I
know would March on Washington if you
try to block out the Sun and take away
our suntan like Floridians have to hand
also I remember growing up in the 80s
they told us that aerosol like Hairspray
cans were bad and everyone's like
they're gonna Outlaw the hairspray cans
but now we're gonna take gargantuan
amounts of aerosol and put it in the sky
it makes no sense that's it we I spent
my whole childhood they were talking
about the ozone right you can't spray
the ozone and then so we had to do the
pump spray and the pump spray didn't
work I'm So Vain that I was like I'll
take climate change if you take away my
Hairspray
that's right you can't have that hotep
the uh this is unintended consequences
this is the kind of thing that once they
do it and then they find out the side
effects it could have I mean could have
the opposite effect right this is the
most racist policy ever that's right
it's racist they're literally trying to
obliterate me I feel attacked
I you know how much I love the sun like
I cannot survive in the cold weather I'm
so anti-white I can't do it
um
my bad my bad
but not seriously though this reminds me
of the movie uh Forrest Gump Forrest
Gump he goes he's fighting the Vietnam
War and it's like raining and raining
rain and rain right and they can't
figure out why is it raining well guess
what apparently there was this thing
called operation Popeye you probably
know about that he's looking at me like
don't say it dude they've been trying to
weaponize weather for a long time
they've been trying to weaponize the
weather for a very long time he just
said it not me so
operation Popeye was basically weather
modification they wanted to make it rain
in all these different places including
Vietnam
um Henry Kissinger was behind this etc
etc
um he's behind everything anyway I
shouldn't have said that either
shot after this
shoot people they'll poison you
in my case it's gonna block out the sun
um but yeah yeah so when I look at this
and I see this stuff happening to me
it's not new they're just telling us
what they're already doing or already
have done unfortunately and you did
touch on that yes what about something
where you if you're gonna block the sun
don't do it in our atmosphere put
something out in space like you know
when they have the uh what do you call
it when the thing gets in front of the
Sun the eclipse right Eclipse yeah what
if you just put a satellite up there to
just go in front of the Sun for like 20
minutes uh at a time what do you think
of that Joe the solar wind would push it
right back into the planet it would be a
massive explosion
it would be awesome but it'd be terrible
yeah but I'll tell you what there is a
little bit of historical precedent for
that because a lot of people think that
the little Ice Age happened in the 1300s
from volcanic explosions and that's kind
of artificially recreating that to cool
the atmosphere incidentally when they
talk about a 1.5 degree rise in
temperature uh they're talking about
that from 1870 the end of the little ice
age uh so we're getting warmer from a
really cold artificially cold through
volcanism uh time period so is it even
that big a deal I don't think that it is
what happened then
[Applause]
scientists that kind of threw me there
wasn't even a script over there
little Ice Age wow okay coming up most
Americans support that
fling from the Supreme Court hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else